Depuis que je suis militaire
Ce n'est pas rigolo, entre nous
Je suis d'une santé précaire
Et je me fais un mauvais sang fou
J'ai beau vouloir me remonter
Je souffre de stous les côtés
J'ai la rate qui s'dilate
J'ai le foi qu'est pas droit
J'ai le ventre qui se rentre
J'ai l'pylore qui s'colore
J'ai le gosier anémié
L'estomac bien trop bas
Et les côtes bien trop hautes
J'ai les hanches qui s'démanchent
L'épigastre qui s'encastre
L'abdomen qui s'démène
Le thorax qui s'désaxe
La poitrine qui s'débine
Les épaules qui se frôlent
J'ai les reins bien trop fins
Les boyaux bien trop gros
J'ai l'sternum qui s'dégomme
Et l'sacrum c'est tout comme
J'ai l'nombril tout en vrille
Et l'coccyx qui s'dévisse
Ah ! bon Dieu qu'c'est embêtant d'être toujours patraque
Ah ! bon Dieu qu'c'est embêtant, je n'suis pas bien portant !
Afin de guérir au plus vite
Un matin tout dernièrement
Je suis allé à la visite
Voir le Major du régiment
"D'où souffrez-vous ?" qu'il m'a demandé
"C'est bien simple !" que j'ai répliqué
J'ai la rate qui s'dilate
J'ai le foi qu'est pas droit
J'ai le ventre qui se rentre
J'ai l'pylore qui s'colore
J'ai l'gosier anémié
L'estomac bien trop bas
Et les côtes bien trop hautes
J'ai les hanches qui s'démanchent
L'épigastre qui s'encastre
L'abdomen qui s'démène
J'ai l'thorax qui s'désaxe
La poitrine qui s'débine
Les épaules qui se frôlent
J'ai les reins bien trop fins
Les boyaux bien trop gros
J'ai l'sternum qui s'dégomme
Et l'sacrum c'est tout comme
J'ai l'nombril tout en vrille
J'ai l'coccyx qui s'dévisse
Et puis j'ai ajouté :
"Voyez-vous, c'n'est pas tout,
J'ai les genoux qui sont mous
J'ai l'fémur qu'est trop dur
J'ai les cuisses qui s'raidissent
Les guibolles qui flageollent
J'ai les chevilles qui s'tortillent
Les rotules qui ondulent
Les tibias raplaplas
Les mollets trop épais
Les orteils pas pareil
J'ai le coeur en largeur
Les poumons tout en long
L'occiput qui chahute
J'ai les coudes qui s'dessoudent
J'ai les seins sous l'bassin
Et l'bassin qu'est pas sain
En plus d'ça, j'vous l'cache pas,
J'ai aussi (quel souci !)
La luette trop fluette
L'oesophage qui surnage
Les gencives qui dérivent
J'ai l'palais qu'est pas laid
Mais les dents, c'est navrant,
J'ai les p'tites qui s'irritent
Et les grosses qui s'déchaussent
Les canines s'ratatinent
Les molaires s'font la paire
Dans les yeux c'est pas mieux
J'ai le droit qu'est pas droit
Et le gauche qu'est bien moche
J'ai les cils qui s'défilent
Les sourcils qui s'épilent
J'ai l'menton qu'est trop long
Les artères trop pépères
J'ai le nez tout bouché
L'trou du cou qui s'découd
Et du coup, voyez-vous
J'suis gêné pour parler
C'est vexant car maintenant
J'suis forcé d'm'arrêter
Ah ! bon Dieu qu'c'est embêtant d'être toujours patraque !
Ah ! bon Dieu qu'c'est embêtant : je n'suis pas bien portant !